mais alors tu es tu as l'air d'un skin
comme ça mais en fait tu es vachement
sympa il paraît
François
diplômés de la Villette alors est-ce que
tu peux nous présenter les autres
Garçons Bouchers
[Musique]
le bassiste calme et pondéré ça existe
depuis combien de temps les garçons
touchés là ça va faire
un peu plus de deux ans maintenant
l'époque où il y avait à Paris tout
toute cette tout ce mouvement
alternatifs indépendant qui a eu à peu
près deux ans à Paris donc vous êtes
contre le top 50 de l'alternatif nous on
est pour le Top 50 si on est dedans et
on est contre on est contre tout ce qui
est dedans actuellement
en dehors de ça vous êtes quand même
pour le retour à la grande musique là il
y a eu les ablettes et que tu verras la
semaine dernière il y avait les
porte-manteaux avec ça ira vous vous
faites mais l'île montant donc c'est le
retour à la grande tradition de la
chanson française de faire non je ne
regrette rien
n'a pas de complexe par rapport au
groupe anglo-saxon surtout
ou bien ou deux ans il y a vraiment rien
du tout en mission anglo-saxonne on a
une culture qui est à la fois une
culture rock
tout ce qu'on attendait quand on était
Momo adolescent et puis en même temps on
entendait la radio tout ce que vous fait
passer comme ce qu'on appelle la chanson
française on peut difficilement nier
l'influence que ça a eu et puis
maintenant bon
plus peur de les chercher ses racines là
en même temps ça dure c'est la grande
réconciliation en quelque sorte alors
toi à part ça tu t'occupes d'une maison
de production qui s'appelle boucherie de
production c'est ça on a créé un label
parce que bon on était on savait très
bien que par le biais des labels
classiques et des ce qu'on appelle les
majeurs compagnie on avait aucune chance
en même temps tout le milieu alternatif
avait des labels qui
bricolaient un petit peu sans vraiment
nous satisfaire donc on a créé notre
propre label
et puis ça a marché tout de suite ce qui
fait qu'on a signé plein de groupes et
que là
les Garçons Bouchers
Pigalle il y a les chihuahua les bébés
d'hôtes La Mano Negra bientôt un groupe
hollandais qu'on vient de signer ça sera
le premier groupe étranger les crabes de
Lyon
et mon on espère bien continuer comme ça
ça marche très bien et puis on a sorti
un peu notre disque de prestige là il y
a environ deux mois qui s'appelle mon
grand frère est un rocker et qui est le
premier le premier album compilation
avec 13 groupes parmi les plus durs au
groupe français à faire un album pour
enfants je crois qu'il y a jamais
vraiment d'album de rock pour enfants de
ce type là fait dans le monde donc on
est on est fier et puis ça marche bien
les momes s'éclatent bien c'est ton côté
instituteur ça si on veut c'est surtout
mon côté anti Chantal Goya et Antilles
Dorothée mais quand tu étais instituteur
c'était comment là c'était un peu le
bordel aussi oui c'est pour ça que je
suis pas excellente c'était comme ça
déjà
maternelle ils ont pas intérêt à
l'ouvrir parce que et les mamans elles
avaient pas les mamans elles avaient pas
peur quand elle t'amenait les petits le
matin voici restez au coin de la rue
puis elle est lancée comme ça
a duré combien de temps oh ça a duré
deux ans deux ans calvaire pour les maux
et ils t'ont foutu dehors ou c'est toi
qui est parti dehors pourquoi qu'est-ce
que tu avais fait
pédagogique c'est-à-dire j'ai même pas
trop tout ce qui était inspecteur et
cetera que vous lui frapper un
inspecteur mais dis-le c'est pas grave à
cette heure-là il regarde pas les
inspecteurs tu peux pas le dire non non
c'est jamais peut-être qu'il y a des
inspecteurs qui achètent des idées de
rock alors
bonnes mentalité comme ça hein c'est
parti pour réussir là une chose qui est
bizarre c'est que tu étais instituteur
mais c'est encore plus bizarre c'est que
tu faisais du folk qui paraît et bah
ouais
les sabots
et jouer de la Vienne du cimer
mais je sais pas ça doit être un jour
une montée de
voilà le gaz carbonique j'ai eu besoin
de d'un apport bucolique
tu la connais avec les douilles sur les
épaules toi
la santé ça t'arrive encore des fois de
faire un peu de folk à la maison le soir
comme ça j'ai fait
dans les Garçons Bouchers il y a du
violon d'accordéon et j'ai appris ça
dans la grande période
de l'harmonique
puis bon j'ai rencontré Monsieur qui lui
était un affreux ce qui nous punk
destroy et c'était ça toi non
tu fais la conduite
et toi tu es un grand branleur un grand
profiter du changement aussi
l'organisation
[Musique]
de pouvoir lui demander gracieusement de
venir participer à notre clip sur le
morceau
carnivore et on vient de finir de
tourner le VIP ça sort quand ça sort
dans un mois à peu près le temps de
monter il y aura Professeur Choron aussi
donc Béatrice Dalle qui découpe de
l'avion à la tronçonneuse
il y a Christophe Salengro
qui fait qui fait un serveur de
restaurant dans un restaurant un peu
bizarre où la salle est très clean et ou
la cuisine ou sinon la cuisine est
particulièrement dégueulasse enfin ça va
être un clip
c'est un jeune réalisateur Jean-Michel
roux qui est en train de faire un
feuilleton de 32 épisodes de 5 minutes
qui est un peu en retour aux séries
serial américain etc un jeune plein
avenir et on vous voit chez Drucker dans
combien de temps une prochaine on
préfère faire ça on va faire ça Badier
donc je sais pas c'est vrai
mais alors tu es tu as l'air d'un skin
comme ça mais en fait tu es vachement
sympa il paraît voilà ce qui sont sympas
il y en a qui sont frappent des skins ça
dépend c'était tout seul et que ils sont
trois ils sont pas sympas c'était trois
ils sont super sympas et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu